as we hear the media complain about
Trump's blunt rhetoric it pays to see
their response when violence follows
their rhetoric one man just tried to
stab a Republican candidate as the fiend
allegedly cursed Trump
this comes as yet another Broadway star
pleads for the president's death where
is John Wilkes Booth when you need right
will I be on the enemies list Johnny
Depp looks terrible I cut back on the
rum now this comes as the cheerleader of
confrontation brags about threatening
Trump supporters all the time you saw at
that time now the media would call this
cause and effect but since it's a
liberal it's just a coincidence
yep all this violent anti Trump rhetoric
has absolutely nothing to do with actual
harm that follows how stupid of us to
think of that if only we had an actual
expert someone who knows firsthand what
left-wing political violence looks like
they need to be denouncing that kind of
activity there's no place for it if
somebody on the right was doing it we'd
be vocally denouncing it they need to be
denouncing that on the left remember him
now his words probably won't matter as
much these days because most victims now
are just those with wounded feelings
because that's what we care about we
hear a lot about Trump's rhetoric as
though it's worse than violent deeds
this after four decades of incendiary
words and deeds churning from the left
guys like Bill Ayers a left wing bomber
who just retired from a university
university that you paid for on 9/11 he
was quoted in the New York Times saying
I don't regret setting bombs I feel we
didn't do enough why do I get the sense
there are more and more people 17 years
later who might agree with him it's the
business of demonization and it seems to
be booming just ask Elyse hmm indeed
Dana was like the kicker yes you like
the kicker the thing is there's never
any follow-up on these things if it's a
right if it's not a righty it's a
one-off it's an isolated incident
yeah something unless if it's on the
right it tends to be a trend yeah
that is extremely frustrating it is
frustrating it seems wand that the media
and Democrats denounce violence when it
suits them no I said I please do that
camp I think it's Trump by the way when
they important the right-wing was all
about beating up people at Trump rallies
like what did Trump say he said you know
what
I don't endorse it but these people have
tremendous passion nothing's ever
happened nothing's ever happen how about
I'd like to punch him in the face says
Trump how about that's any good we'd
knock the crap words from oh so these
words I'm talking Oh what about
Charlotte slow you want some bad deeds
they wait to know there's enough of that
to go can play that game I'm not playing
any game on thanks the least deserves
all our sympathies and he has grounds to
speak on this with great authority
giving us the suffering that he went
through but I'm just saying it strikes
me that when Maxine Waters and we've
seen this tape a hundred times now on
Fox I guess we like it but when Maxine
Waters says it's okay to confront people
people say oh that's violence that's not
the kind of violence that we were seeing
at Trump rallies it's funny because she
just admitted she actually does threaten
people is not talking about like what
happened with saris Huckabee Sanders
it's okay to harass people people say
hey I don't like what you're doing we're
Americans we have a right to say that in
a world where feelings matter unless
you're a Republican are you I think
Maxine's sin Jedidiah is that she's
promoting everything but democracy she's
not saying vote like go out and vote
she's saying impeach which is
essentially saying overthrow yeah she's
saying basically bully and used the
media and use everything to when the
democratic process that he got elected
he's everybody's president I keep
hearing liberals say oh he's not my
president he's everybody's president and
the media selective coverage I always
think back to the Tea Party rallies that
I went to all the time and how the media
was scouring those crowds looking for
violence looking for a sign that they
could say was inciting violence and then
that same media ignored actual violence
that was going on at Occupy Wall Street
where people were getting raped and
there were accusations of rape in these
tents in New York City and Beyond and
the media's refusal they'll hold trial
two tasks for a language that I'll agree
in some cases is not good but they won't
hold people accountable for actual
violence against people on the right
somehow the rhetoric matters to them
more than the actual acts of violence
because it depends on where it comes
from I understand I understand why
people act violet because if you have
been taught for years that the other
side is the oppressor and that you are
the oppressed it's not about being wrong
or right it's about being moral and
immoral or evil so the red so the
Republicans and conservatives will be
always be the target of violence because
they are seen as immoral or evil but
because the ends justify the means yes
that's how they've been raised and
that's what they believe and they're
like infants if they don't get their way
they will scream and they will punch and
I understand the frustration because
Trump's winning and he rubs it in their
face and he pushes their buttons and
they're completely shut out of power on
every level of the federal excuse me dr.
Watters dr. you were raised by liberal
parents were you raised to be violent
I'm saying they've been conditioned
because we've discussed Hollywood has
done a lot of disgusting things and
Maxine Waters as you know they traffic
in this type of violent rhetoric and I'm
not blaming these people for the actions
of one deranged individual I'm saying
they're not condemning these people when
it comes out this man who has Trump
derangement syndrome just tried to stab
a Republican congressional candidate and
I haven't heard this once on the network
news anywhere outside of Fox News or the
Internet where is the condemnation
coming in from leadership and the
Democratic Party says we don't condone
this type of stuff well I don't hear it
at all I hear crickets
the guy's nuts but you're not he's not
sane you're not blaming I agree you're
not blaming all those people but they
need to take a stand and condemn this
stuff don't do that they will one person
will come out who happens to have a
comment on their Facebook page that's
pro Trump and now it's all Trump
supporters all Republicans are violent
they don't give that same goodness
there's one practical thing that could
be done the Federal Election Commission
could change the law to allow campaign
contributions to be used for personal
security
and if you are a member or you are a
candidate and you are concerned you
should be allowed to do that it would be
fully disclosed and I know that that is
a proposal in front of them right now I
think they should just go ahead and do
it but that in your good suggestion
Journal smoke and smoke it oh my
goodness Dana what's happened to her
ever since they legalized you you're a
bad employee I can't even keep up